a few stories you think you'll be  talking about today since January ice  has arrested about 250 foreign students  at a fake university in Michigan it's  part of a sting operation by federal  agents the University of Farmington was  opened in 2015 as a guise by ice  officials in enticed foreign-born  students mostly from India who had  arrived legally in the United States on  legitimate student visas but the  government says the phony University was  a pay to play scheme the students used  to remain in the United States under a  student visa some of the students were  arrested and deported while others await  trial in the United States a lot of  people have criticized ice because of  their growing power the government says  the students should have known that this  was not a real University that they were  just using it to have a student visa to  say that they may be nice and then right  soon these right